[Música]
hace algunos meses platicaba yo con una
compañera del doctorado es un hombre es
puya puya paul cuya compañera amiga del
doctorado nosotros estábamos en eeuu
normalmente conversamos en inglés porque
no hay otra manera o por señas le
preguntaba yo voy a cuando con qué
frecuencia hablas tu idioma de tu lengua
nativa- aquí en eeuu porque resulta ser
que en india es una nación multicultural
y se hablan n cantidad de idiomas y
entonces es muy difícil que fuera del
país tú encuentres a alguien que hable
el mismo idioma que tú entonces ella
incluso tiene un novio con el que ni
siquiera habla en alguno de sus idiomas
nativos y no habla en inglés
entonces
y yo le pregunto con qué frecuencia en
el estudio viene decía pues solamente
cuando loco mi mamá por teléfono o algún
amigo
y
y aquí en boston como lo haces y me
decía pues no aquí cada vez puede
encontrar bien con tiempo hablan el
mismo idioma
y le decía yo bueno y cómo te sientes
cuando eso sucede y su respuesta pues
fue un poco a mí me resultó muy
interesante me dijo pues a mí eso me
hace muy feliz me hace muy feliz puede
hablar en mi idioma
antes de segundos años yo empecé a
interesarme en estos temas que están
relacionados con por un lado con la
cultura y por otro lado con el bienestar
me interesó porque bueno como promotor
cultural como gente que ha estado
trabajando en el tema de la gestión
cultural
he visto programas de intervención
nacionales federales estatales e incluso
municipales en donde se dice muchas
veces que las actividades culturales de
alguna manera minimiza la violencia o
impacta en el bienestar de las personas
pero en muchos de estos casos la verdad
es que se realizan todas estas
intervenciones o programas sin mucha
evidencia de lo que sucede sin mucha sin
saber exactamente cómo funcionan operan
estos mecanismos detrás de estas
intervenciones entonces a mí me a mí me
interesó empecé a preguntar cómo sucede
qué pasa que podemos investigar sobre
esto no cuando nosotros nos preguntamos
cuando me pregunto sobre esta asociación
entre cultura y bienestar
bueno empiezo con unas muy breves
definiciones que ustedes pueden ver en
la pantalla primero por cultura que se
entiende esta es una definición de la
unesco de la declaración de 1982 por
cultura se entiende con un conjunto de
rasgos distintivos que
a una comunidad o un grupo de personas
pero además la cultura engloba las artes
y las letras los modos de vida derechos
fundamentales valores lenguaje etcétera
etcétera según la unesco
y por otro lado el bienestar cuando yo
hablo de bienestar me refiero al
bienestar subjetivo que no es otra cosa
que la percepción que tienen los
individuos de
de sus condiciones de vida es decir cómo
me siento yo respecto a mis condiciones
de salud con mis condiciones económicas
con mis condiciones familiares etcétera
etcétera
estas dos ideas han sido se ha intentado
establecer qué asociaciones existen
entre ellas es muy hoy en día se ha
llegado como a la conclusión o hasta
dónde vamos ahora en la en la literatura
especializada es que bussi que en efecto
hay una relación entre la cultura o
entre esto que entendemos por cultura y
entre esto que entendemos por bienestar
estas relaciones como hasta ahora se ha
entendido más bien como muy débil no
como como que esta relación no ha sido
muy claramente identificada y por qué es
esto porque normalmente en los estudios
relacionados con la cultura mucho y el
bienestar normalmente lo que se estudia
no es la cultura con todos estos
elementos que mencionaba yo previamente
sino además si no normalmente lo que se
estudia solamente la participación en
las artes o las actividades artísticas
con el bienestar o con algunos
componentes del bienestar es decir
cuando por ejemplo si la gente asiste al
teatro al cine si participa en talleres
de música danza pintura o si la gente
compra música
y comprar libros etc esto es eso es
realmente lo que se está estudiando en
relación con con la cultura pero todos
los demás componentes que conforman o
que podrían identificarse en la
literatura como elementos que
constituyen a la cultura pues están
siendo no están siendo donde está no
están siendo totalmente relacionados o
no están siendo investigados en su
relación con el bienestar no es entonces
aquí lo que encontramos es que aspectos
como el lenguaje los estos modos de vida
las redes sociales económicas y
políticas que establecen una comunidad
también la identidad cultural la memoria
histórica el patrimonio la pertenencia
el sentido de territorialidad todas
estas ideas que engloban a la cultura de
acuerdo con muchos autores la pregunta
es
que entonces como están relacionadas o
como están vinculadas con el bienestar
de las personas y de las comunidades en
el 2002
el gobierno de nueva zelanda
promueve o emite una ley a la que
denomina la ley de las comunidades y
esta ley lo que abdel de lo que habla es
que establece un concepto a una idea que
no había sido abordada anteriormente a
la que ellos denominan bienestar
cultural el bienestar cultural ellos
ellos generan esta está esta idea
pensando en las comunidades indígenas
particularmente la comunidad maorí que
vive nueva zelanda y como esta comunidad
maorí ha sido segregada excluida y como
podía como se podría integrar con el
resto de la comunidad particularmente
cómo se puede integrar con la comunidad
blanca entonces aquí la pregunta
ellos producen este concepto dicen que
es el bienestar cultural y esta idea de
bienestar cultural de ellos la definen
como el goce
la satisfacción la felicidad producida a
partir de este contacto con todos estos
elementos que mencionaba previamente el
lenguaje las tradiciones costumbres
valores
esta idea ha sido muy muy poco estudiada
y
y algunos otros algunos países la han
retomado también países particularmente
del norte global
por ejemplo algunos países están
colindando con el polo norte canadá
suecia y noruega también están
estudiando ahora algo que ya me llaman
bienestar cultural y de las comunidades
aborígenes las comunidades originarias
que se encuentran pues en estas zonas
del polo norte
puesto que nos permite pues bueno porque
es importante hablar o estudiar
esta idea sobre por qué por qué pensar
en que la cultura y el bienestar tendría
que están asociados o por qué por qué
sea importante bueno sea importante
porque por dos razones creo yo
primero porque por un lado el bienestar
cultural se encuentra en una especie de
continuo en el en el que del otro lado
se encuentra algo que podríamos llamar
malestar cultural que no es otra cosa
que la suma de discriminación xenofobia
racismo exclusión migración y tenemos el
bienestar por lo que si nosotros
pensamos o eventualmente queremos
combatir o pensamos en queremos acabar
con la discriminación con el racismo con
la exclusión con la migración y con
todas estas cosas que nos aquejan hoy
día de manera global cómo podemos
combatirlo tenemos que pensar que hay
del otro lado y del otro lado creo creo
que se encuentren bienestar cultural
también habría que pensar la idea de
fiesta cultural se encuentra
fundamentada en los derechos humanos y
los derechos humanos
exhortan protegen vigilan a la dignidad
humana al cumplimiento de la dignidad
humana y particularmente los derechos
culturales porque en este caso los
derechos culturales y su foco se centra
en la identidad cultural como un
componente de la dignidad humana
por tanto sería importante empezar a
considerar esta idea del bienestar
cultural como un componente importante
de bienestar de los sujetos las personas
de la de la satisfacción de la felicidad
y todas estas ideas algunas algunos
organismos internacionales como la usb y
a nivel nacional
el inegi han intentado o han estado
midiendo desde hace algunos años ya han
estado midiendo o evaluando
el bienestar de las personas en muchas
de estas muchas de estas mediciones o
evaluaciones que se centran la mayor
preponderancia todos los aspectos
económicos principalmente por ejemplo
ingreso y en algunos casos aspectos
sociales
a toda esta idea de todos los
componentes culturales se han soslayado
y porque se han soslayado porque no
porque se piensan no tienen ningún poder
económico entonces habría que cambiar la
manera en que estamos pensando en el
bienestar
hoy es decir hoy día se sigue pensando
en el bienestar solamente como tiene una
casa tiene un auto tiene un buen ingreso
pero no se está pensando en tiene
contacto con su lengua puede practicar
sus tradiciones o costumbres puede
practicar su religión sí o no
para quien es importante esto pues en
general para todos habría que decirlo
pero específicamente no solamente para
las comunidades indígenas sino para
otros grupos minoritarios pienso yo en
los migrantes por ejemplo como un grupo
importante que el que podía interesar
medido considerar la idea de bienestar
cultural nosotros los migrantes que se
van de un país a otro también los
migrantes dentro de una misma de una de
las fronteras del mismo país la gente
que se desplace un estado a otro también
aquellos que son que han sido o que
migran por razones
como la guerra es decir desplazados
migración forzada todos ellos también
podrían ser objeto o podrían podríamos
evaluar qué sucede con su bienestar
cultural también las otros otros grupos
que no sé qué no se están moviendo pero
que están aquí por ejemplo las
comunidades afrodescendientes que sucede
con con su contacto con la cultura lo
estamos negando lo estamos visibilizando
o lo estamos
lo estamos aniquilando estudian que
estamos haciendo al respecto
me gustaría concluir esta esta breve
conversación con una idea de alan turing
el sociólogo francés que habla acerca de
la lectura índice y que las guerras
hasta ahora han sido guerras por raza
por etnia por recursos económicos no
pero que en el futuro y yo creo que el
día no tan futuro estaremos las nuestras
guerras van a ser guerras culturales es
decir la confrontación entre unas
culturas y las otras por tanto habría
que pensar cómo estamos ahora mismo
viviendo evaluando considerando pensando
en el bienestar
y qué componentes o qué ideas nos
conectan con este bienestar
muchas gracias
y
[Música]